[SOUND] Great job colorizing
your command line output
in the previous project.
Not only will the text be much easier
to see out here in the wilderness, but
it'll also help you in your
future development career.
You are now ready to start the
simulation part of your survivor camp.
The purpose of the game is
to take contestants and
put them against each other in
a series of challenges to declare
an ultimate winner.
You'll be using your knowledge of Ruby's
object orientation, as well as TDD,
test driven development, to ensure
that a new winner wins every time.
The test driven development workflow
may seem a little strange at first, but
that's to be expected.
Learning how to read tests and make them
pass is an incredibly useful skill for
all developers.
So if you're ready for your next
survivor challenge, let's get started.